good morning and good afternoon everyone
welcome to today's webinar entitled get
closer to the truth stellaris confocal
reimagined
being presented today by dr petra haas
and dr julia roberti of leica
microsystems
my name is andrea i'm with labroot and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational seminar is brought
to you by labyrinths and sponsored by
lycra
microsystems for more information on our
sponsor you can click
on the sponsor logo on the left side of
your screen
or visit leica microsystems.com
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive so we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you like
at any time during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button the presenters will be answering
as many questions as we have time for
at the end of their presentation you can
also use this
ask a question box to report any trouble
you have in hearing the presentation
or you can also click on the support tab
for any help you might need
and that's found at the top right of the
presentation window
i'd like to now introduce today's
presenters dr petra haas
senior product manager and dr julia
roberti product manager for advanced
confocal imaging
both of leica microsystems for complete
biographies of our speakers i invite you
to visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen but with that
i'll go ahead and turn it over to our
speakers to get things started
thank you so much this is julia speaking
it's great to be here today
to open together a new chapter in
leicanconfocal microscopy history
we will talk about innovation together
with petra and
we will talk about why we have pushed
ourselves
to make the best technology available to
you
for your research and
we started imagining how it would be
if you could have the power to see more
the potential to discover more and the
productivity
to do more and in doing so
we have re-imagined confocal microscopy
so you can acquire more accurate and
reliable data
to prove your hypothesis you can extract
a new dimension of information from
every sample and
increase the scientific impact of your
research
and to allow you to set up complex
experiments
in a few clicks and
in a nutshell we have reimagined
confocal microscopy
to get you closer to the truth and so
our new confocal microscope solaris
was born and we have two great
products we have pilaris 5 which sets a
new standard
in confocal imaging and we have
hilarious 8
to gain more knowledge about the
specimen from different
angles
the diaries is built on three
pillars and three attributes
stellaris gives you the power
to see more to get and collect more
accurate and reliable data
pilaris also gives you the potential to
discover more
and this is related to the access to
additional
dimensions of information from which you
can get additional insight
and this is using lifetime-based
information
that allows you to explore the function
of molecules
in the cellular context and finally
stellaris gives you the productivity to
do more
and this productivity means that you can
set up
an experiment in a few clicks instead of
setting
up a bunch of individual imaging
parameters
and it's the ability to get
great image quality at the speed you
need for
your results and it's also the ability
to navigate and locate the
interesting regions in your sample and
be
very efficient in your workflow
so we will go in details about this
attribute so now i will hand over the
presentation to petra
thank you julia um so actually
i would like uh to start by telling you
what is behind the power to see more
so why is it relevant to deliver more
power
so first aspect of that is that more
power
gives you more brightness to see more
details
so this also provides expanded
multi-color flexibility
and it improves your gender life cell
imaging
capabilities
how does delirius give more brightness
and more detail
so this already
is a a very nice multi-color image
captured with a traditional confocal
and and here on the right side is what
you will get with
gallares so ela stellaris allows you
to detect even low abundance species at
endogenous levels
through its enhanced sensitivity and you
get
quantitative results due to the
proprietary new photon counting
approach that i will explain a bit later
so one key innovation of the stellaris
platform
is the new power heidi detector family
with its three members
that i would like to introduce to you
now so a heidi s
which will be our new standard for
stellaris building on
silicon based technology and we believe
that it will actually set new standards
due to its all-arounder capabilities and
there's the heidi x
this is an excellent detector for
functional imaging
based on leica gasp hybrid technology
and there is a new variant of the gas
based detector
the heidi r which is especially suited
for applications in the near infrared
range so let's look in more detail
starting with the power heidi app it is
the
using silicon based multi-pixel photon
counter technology
it's actually as you can see on this
graphics an array of individual detector
cells
and a photocathode material is on top
which receives the incoming photons they
are converted into photoelectrons
and each cell here has its own avalanche
diode
that converts the single photoelectrons
in charged pulses
which are recorded at the anode and so
despite being an array
all signals are wired together in one
output
so what is behind this exceptional
performance that we're gonna
demonstrate in the next few slides so
in addition to the detector chip this
ship is
actually combined with leica engineering
which includes proprietary
electronics and optomechanics and the
same applies to the implementation of an
efficient cooling scheme
to suppress dark noise so what do we do
with the output signals that are coming
from this detector
so for the charge pulses emerging from
the detector
two independent pathways are available
to process those signals
resulting in two offered operating modes
so first there's the analog mode which
is suitable
for high dynamic range imaging and this
means that it's very robust in terms of
the signal levels that the detector can
handle
and second there's the photon counting
mode
where extremely low dark noise allows to
capture
even fainted signals and it makes it the
choice for quantitative measurements
also it allows to perform tourism
lifetime based imaging
that you will hear later about
so the other two members of the family
are heidi x and heidi r
both deploying gasps based hybrid
technology
and the function of these detectors is
depicted in the scheme here
where again we have a photocathode
material on top
where incident light is collected and is
converted
into photoelectrons and each individual
photoelectron
is being accelerated by a high voltage
to the photon anode
where a charge pulse is generated and
read out at the anode
so ideally each incident photon is
converted into
one charged pulse emerging from that
detector
and this is the basis for the photon
counting capabilities of the heidi x
and heidi r to deliver the imaging
of low signals with extremely little
dark noise
so ideally suited for quantification and
again fluorescence lifetime based
imaging um
so what are we doing with the photons
that our power heidi detectors
collect with deniary systems so if we
look at
how conventional photon counting works
you can see that
if photons are coming sparsely
everything is good
so um one one photon delivers one
one one signal basically um
and so but if if if photons arrive
closer to each other there is a danger
that they cannot be resolved
since they are below the pulse pair
resolution of the detector
in this example conventional counting
would actually miss
one count so this is where the counting
scheme
from stellaris differs here we are
making use of
pulse width information and this gives
us the chance to know
if one photon or more photons actually
triggered a given pulse
and this enables a better capability to
count signals
and it also makes quantification better
as well
so at low abundance imaging
conventional counting and power counting
give the same results
at high signal intensities power
counting significantly enhance
detection sensitivity and also the
dynamic range
the visual that you see here shows the
benefits of power counting
so signals coming from the detectors are
shown as a function of the excitation
intensity
in grey you can see how conventional
counting behaves
it increases in a linear manner at low
levels
but then you can see the saturation
behavior of the detector
and the benefit is that with power
counting you significantly
increase the dynamic range of the
detector
and also you increase the linearity
here on this slide you see a
side-by-side comparison
of images that were taken with
conventional photon counting versus both
taken with stellaris power counting
and you can appreciate the gain in image
contrast
in particular this is beneficial on
images taken with a resonance scanner
where the time on each pixel is very
short to acquire photons
so you are working normally in the
regime where you benefit most from the
power counting
so stellaris gives you also access to
expanded multicolor flexibility
what is this good for so if you look
here on the left
you see an actin staining where a light
is connected
all the way up beyond 700 nanometers
this is what you can see on a
traditional controller system
with dollars you see much more in this
example two additional markers in the
red range of the spectrum
are acceptable um so you add basically
two more markers
beyond what is possible on the
conventional microscope
and don't forget that the rest of the
spectrum is still available to generate
more contacts to answer your scientific
questions
so you profit from a broader choice of
markers due
to both the extended excitation and also
detection
in the near infrared range
so one innovation driver which allows
for this is the next generation of of
white light lasers
so um the white light laser as such
emits as
its name suggests like white light
composed of all available wavelengths
and the way how you basically pick
the the wavelength you're interested in
is
facilitated by our proprietary um
technology which is acoustic optical
beam splitter the aops
so the aobs allows to pick
up to eight lasers simultaneously in
nanometer position
that can be tailored to the optimal
excitation wavelength of the surface in
your sample
so the leica whitehead laser provides
complete spectral freedom
and with stellaris we offer two new
variants of the white light laser
so on the stellaris five we have
we cover a range from 485 nanometers to
685
nanometers which allows to excite
already a fair number of redshifted dies
and standardised page comes with a white
light laser
which goes from 440 nanometers to 790
so it extended both into the blue and
into the red
so this laser is ideally suited both for
lifetime based imaging
of cfp-based sensors for example as well
as
optimal tool to cover the whole visible
and near-infrared spectrum
so how does hilarious improve
your lifestyle imaging capabilities um
this is basically enabled by the synergy
of some of the key innovations i just
introduced
so the power heidi family the spectral
freedom of the white dead laser
and not to forget the fully redesigned
optics for enhanced transmission
capabilities
the image here by the way shows a
configuration
with four height x detectors and one
heidi s
which is sitting in the space in between
so
simultaneous five color life cell
imaging is at your
disposal so with this
i would give back to julia who will now
tell you more about the potential of
solaris
thanks petra so now let's move on
and i want to talk with you now about
the potential of solaris to discover
more
and as i already mentioned this is
related
to the use of lifetime based information
to get
new insights about your sample so
this has the potential to really
increase
the scientific impact of your research
and your results
and we see this as
that it will become really a
transformation
of how microscopy is done
so with this potential you can explore
a new dimension of information and also
it gives you the possibility to
multiplex
beyond the spectral options so you can
gain access to functional imaging
and we will see now in the next slide
how we can
achieve this so the technology
that is supporting uh this hilarious
potential
has a name and uh this name is thousands
so thousands is a set of tools
based on person's lifetime it gives
access to
this powerful additional information
qualitative and
semi-quantitative and it's gateway
technology and it's also average photon
arrival times that are
processed at the fpga level
so when i talk about this uh
exploring a new dimension i want to show
you uh what i need
this with this uh example so we have now
here a very nice image of arabidopsis
and this here on the left is what you
would see
when you do intensity based measurements
so here we have the possibility of
observing a chloroplast by the
endogenous viruses
we also have actin that has been stained
with a
life act venus and we have the
membranes stained with trophenium iodide
so i can get very nice structural
details but i don't get
any more contra and contrast and it's
fairly difficult to see where uh the
membranes and where the chloroplasts are
sitting
but with stellaris here on the right
side
of the image i get this additional
information
and then i can identify the chloroplast
and the membranes and the
actin filaments and this is all
enabled by one of the thousands tools
which is tau contrast so i want to
explain how how contrast works now and
for this
i will use as a basis a very simplified
version of the japlosky uh
diagram when it i i can see
how the fluorescence process happens so
i have
my molecules in ground state and then
they are excited
and they will emit fluorescence and as
an
outcome of this process i will have a
fluorescence intensity that i can
measure as a number of photons
and i will have a fluorescent lifetime
how can i measure the person's lifetime
that is basically
the average time that the molecules stay
in this excited state
well we have our wildlife lasers that
have
that are post laser source so then i can
uh use this laser source and i can use
the uh photon counting capabilities of
our detectors
do measure the time it takes for the
photon to be detected
and in principle uh i could
from this information uh estimate
the present lifetime of my system
but what i will do is for thousands
i will not go all the way to
fluorescence lifetime
i will use the information that comes
from the photon arrival time
of the photons emitted by my molecules
so for tau contrast i have
my number of photons my fluorescence
intensity
and i have the photon arrival time so
what uh cellarius will do is it will
take this
information and it will process it at
the fcga level
pixel by texture and on the fly and the
outcome of the tau contrast experiment
will be fluorescence intensity and in
each pixel the average photon arrival
time
so to show you how it works for the
example i show you
i have the pixels and i will have the
intensity
in each one and i will also have
color coded the information of the
photon arrival types
i will do this for the entire image
and with tau contrast i get instantly
this arrival time
information with every image in life and
in acquisition mode
and this information reflects the
environment the microenvironment
environment on the of the molecule and
that gives me
extra information another aspect
of this additional information is the
capability to separate
pieces beyond the spectral options and
that
to illustrate that i have another
example
so i have here a sample that has been
stained
uh with a knife act in your green that
you see here on
a traditional or intensity based
measurement as you see here on the left
in yellow i also have microtracker green
for the mitochondria
also here and these two um these two
stains i detect in the green channel
and then i set a red channel in which
i'm
detecting a nuclear stain not red
and spear tubulin and this both
dice you see here in grey and as you can
see
with intensity information i'm not able
to distinguish really
where the actin and where the
mitochondria are speaking and the same
happens with nucleus
and the tubulin when i apply
the thousands technology in solaris what
i get is out of
two detectors four nitride based
channels
so now i can distinguish and i can
identify
the mitochondria and the actin filament
and i can also see where my
microtubules are and my nuclear stain
so this is enabled by a thousands tool
that is called
towel separation and i want to go
into details of how it's implemented
so again we are working with uh
with our sample and we will get our
presence intensity and
we can also get the photon arrival time
so again working with this information
at the fpga what i will have
is a gate-based multi-component fit
and from this multi-component fit that
works in the background and on the slide
the system will generate a
diagram of the lifetime component
and that added to a gating approach
will produce as an outcome lifetime
based
separated channels so there will be
intensity
uh channels in which i will be able to
distribute the photons according to the
species
from they come where they come from and
these pieces
differ in their fluorescent lifetime so
i can identify
and i can separate them in the examples
i showed you
uh i will have for the first detector
then lifetime based channel one
and a lifetime based channel two and
then i have the same for the second
detector
and then i can distinguish the four uh
different
uh structures that i was i was labeling
with different
uh fluorescence lifetime molecules
so tau separation allows me to identify
pieces
uh with every image even when the
spectra are
fully overlapping so
with this uh i would like to close the
potential of the last chapter and the
person's lifetime based
aspect and i will hand over again to
petra that will talk about
the productivity of stellar
so thank you julia so now uh let's
uh wrap that up with by talking about
the last pillar of stellars which is
productivity
and it's the productivity to do more
um so belarus allows setting up complex
experiments
in a few clicks instead of setting up
individual imaging parameters
and this also then results in less user
training
to get really to excellent results so
um at the heart of of doing more
there's something that we call the image
compass and
let me quickly tell you a little bit
about the guiding principles that
we had in mind when when this was
developed so we wanted really to achieve
that the user sample
is in the center of setting up an
experiment so
it should be able to set up without a
lot of technical
priority knowledge an image and to get a
high quality
multi-color image really fast also
the interface should provide the feeling
of full control to the user
so giving the feedback required to know
exactly what's going on
all the time and and finally we we
wanted to reduce the complexity as a
prerequisite to add new functionality
basically the functionality you just
heard about from julia when she was
mentioning
the towel contrast and towel separation
features so now let's have a look at how
that actually works
so basically the only thing you need to
know is how the specimen under the
microscope has been labeled
and based on this information you pick a
fluorophore from the available lists of
dyes and drag it into into a testing
and the response is that each time a
triad of excitation laser
spectral detection window and respective
emission spectrum is activated by the
system
and also what you can see is that an
addition of a new die
always triggers an attack optimization
based on the new fluorophore scenario
that you create
by doing so um
stellaris also allows you to be fast
across scales in tiny space
so having the resonance scanner
available by a single button click in
the software
gives you immediate access to high speed
imaging
here on the left you see a lifestyle
imaging with an endosomal marker
at 50 frames per second if now we
activate
rolling average image quality is
improved big time
while preserving the temporal resolution
that is
giving credit to the dynamic of your
sample so
at the same time raw data is always
stored so it's possible to revisit that
in order to to adjust it to the dynamic
of your sample that you might observe
only after the acquisition
so how does the rolling average work um
basically once it's activated
it's applied also in live mode and
the more frames have been acquired the
better the image quality gets
basically up to the number of frames
that you have defined
and from here on the actual
average starts to roll um during
acquisition
the scheme is slightly different here as
well images get better all the way
here in this example up all the way to
the fourth frame
and from there on the actual image
quality and display in the viewer gets
made
slightly desynchronized and in this
example again
when for example the fifth frame is
displayed
the acquisition is actually already busy
with the ninth frame and so on
so um on top of that
um to better adjust to the dynamics of
the sample
as a user you can control how much the
remote frames
are actually taken into consideration
for the calculation of the central frame
so the different acquisition schemes
that i have just introduced here
are basically making sure that when you
set up your experiment in live mode
you get already an estimate of how the
final results will look like
now imagine that you can add the power
of lightning to rolling average
data set in this example you can see
what you can achieve so on the left side
you see raw data
acquired with resonance scanner
multi-color
and on the right side this is a
combination of
rolling average in this case actually
it's rolling accumulation because the
images have been acquired in counting
modes
and plus lightning processing so
there is a fully integrated workflow of
rolling average with lightning and the
resonant
scanner last but not least
i want to mention our fantastic
navigator tool
which will give you the ability to
freely navigate through
your sample and explore relevant details
instantly in full quality and by the way
this sequence shows an additional level
of details made possible
by towson so the structural details that
you can see here
the colors that arise from the different
at the different structures are
basically lifetime based information
which is revealed by
tau contrast that was previously
introduced by
julia so solaris really gives you the
productivity
to do more so
denarius is offered in different
configurations
including a broad range of modalities
such as for example
dead falcon dive and dlf
and on this overview can you can see the
differences between
solari 5 and rs8 regarding for example
the availability of the power heidi's
and also the modalities that i have just
mentioned
calcium image compass lightning rolling
average and the navigator
are at the core of both microscopes
with this we have already come to an end
i and julia we would like to thank you
for
staying all the way to the end and and
now we would like to open up for live
questions
thank you thanks
all right wow thank you so much those
images were amazing
that was great we did have a lot of
questions come in
so we will get into those right away
if you still have a question you'd like
to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
that is located on the far
left of your screen okay i'm going to go
ahead and get
to some of the questions that came in um
the first one
for the nir is there a reduction of qe
at the lower
end of frequencies for detection for
instance 488
okay thank you very much for that
question um
it is um if you look at our power heidi
detective family
we have different types of detectors as
i had described
um the heidi um r so
which is the the dedicated detector for
the nir
area actually has a lower qe
in this range of 488 so there
you you would not see a lot on the other
hand if you look at the heidi s detector
this is really a all-rounder and you
would see that it performs really
really well across the whole visible
spectrum so you would see
a good signal from from blue
all the way into the near infrared
okay excellent um next question let me
just look at my list
um is this let's see it says maybe
you'll get to this
but i would love to know if given you
had a very bright tandem
fret pair of cfpyfp
how quickly can you capture a fret
signal
my users work with cardiomyocytes and we
would like to use
a tension sensor at high speed
thanks for the question actually so it's
a really
great uh question very interesting so
of course um we can measure uh
changes uh in the so based on the
thousands
tools very fast and the
main thing that one needs to consider
here
is uh how many photons you can connect
so the photon statistics the photon
budget
if this is a very bright tendon then the
next thing i would look into is the
change that you would observe in your uh
thread
sensor so when it's in one form and in a
different form
so if there's enough difference then uh
yeah of course you would be able to see
it and you would be able to capture it
uh
very fast given that you have enough
photos
okay excellent um let's
see um another one came in does the
rolling average apply for highly dynamic
objects
that move faster than 10 to 20
micrometers per second
um i mean yes of course i mean if you
work with the resonance scanner
and you set that a resonance scanner to
an image format
that allows you to have a high frame
rate
so for example you can go up to
something like
290 frames per second and like this you
could of course also resolve
these kinds of movements and having
this high frame rate also allows you to
to use
rolling average on those samples to
increase um
image quality while at the same time
keep
the temporal resolution
okay excellent um another one how many
photons do you need for tau separation
to work
thank you so um we
give an estimate of how many counts
you need to find in in each pixel
and as a rule of thumb we would say
you can have so if you have 50 to 100
photos that's a good
a good starting point so that would be
the answer so okay at least 50
photos okay
next question how fast can you acquire
tau
contrast images
so uh as fast as your confocal imaging
speed goes so we can keep up the
the speed that you would do for your
intensity based
imaging and get the tau contrast image
of course again you need to consider
here your photon budget
so
okay um next question can stellaris
microscopes be used for
multi-photon cars and srs imaging
modalities
so uh yes um as you could see on
on this slide here
um um the stellaris comes in
solaris five variant and also as a
stellaris
eight and the stellaris eight is really
the platform that allows you to add all
different
modalities like multi-photons and cars
that that have been
asked for here so yeah
okay great um next
can you mix and match high d r and high
dx
to cover the full range of wavelengths
without reduction
in the qe
um i mean yes and no
you um if you if you have a system where
you can
um uh where you have these different
detectors available
then um having having the heidi s and
the heidi r
and the heidi x is actually really good
to get the best
out at each individual location of the
spectral range
but it's not that you have the the same
q e
all over the the full the full range so
you have a curve
which is dropping towards the near
infrared but you still get that very
good signal out there
okay great um is the
difference in photon counting leading to
a large count rate
the difference so that the fact that we
have now the power counting
enables us actually yes to collect more
photons reliable so we can go from
really
small count rates and have excellent
signal there but we can also go
with samples that that provide that that
give more photons and be in a very good
linear regime there as well yes
okay um next do you need special probes
to see at more
red shifted wavelengths
yes so um basically there are um
quite a large number a nice number of
uh commercially available floral fours
that
now with this uh near infrared range
expanded range
we can very nicely implement in the
labeling and then having the rest of the
of the spectrum available
so yeah so it's they are not
exotic options so those are things that
we showed that you can
purchase in different forms and apply it
to your saying
okay okay next
how does sample depth and structural
complexity
affect the lifetime imaging
um can you repeat the question
sure yeah how does sample depth
and structural complexity affect the
lifetime imaging
i apologize if there's a typo in there
i'm not sure how to correct it
yes so i am not so sure so in
principle so the um
so we can collect the arrival times of
the photon
so even if the sample i would say
even if the sample is very complex we
can
and if you image it uh properly and you
cycle it correctly then you can get to
those
structural details and you can very
nicely characterize
it with the arrival of time information
of the totems i'm not
so sure if that is uh where this
question is um coming from
okay well maybe that's one you can
follow up with on email just to make
sure that
that we've gotten it clearly uh sure um
so
this one's a little more straightforward
um can you use
alexa dyes or only proprietary
fluorescent dyes and what about
photo bleaching with the stellaris
device
so of course you can use um
any dye so um all guys are
welcome so it's uh yeah so
our confocal is suited for
any commercially available or developed
in your lab
uh floral force and uh what was the
second part of the question also
so yeah i mean uh photo bleaching
yeah so of course if you so if you
choose a good fluorophore then you would
get uh excellent results and
um yeah so with the in the way that we
have implemented
uh the white light base the detectors
and the
optics we made sure that you can image
in
fix or in live specimens with a
very low laser
conditions and then you get excellent
quality
okay and next does tau separate
sorry just lost my question there
does tau separation get determined by
the machine
automatically
yes so there's that there's an
integrated uh
workflow and then algorithm that works
in
at the background and then you get this
result automated
so you still can use it find
[ __ ] function to determine the uh
so the distributions where you want to
set them or manually but
it's done automatically by the system
okay next what if you stain for a
protein
in different cell types and the
environment in those distinct
cells change the way the actin shows
different lifetimes
wouldn't you get different colors for
the same epitope
okay so that's a long question
and uh if you would have i would say if
you have a probe that
when you use it in different cell types
then it reacts to the micro environment
differently than you would get for the
set spectral window if you keep the
spectral window constant
you would get your intensity based
measurement and your
color let's say would be the same
the corresponding to that spectral
window and what you will see is a
change in the towel construct
based on the different in response to
the microenvironment
okay and this next one has two parts
can stellaris 8 have both wll
and 405 nanometer laser and can it have
five power s
detectors inside and four more on the x1
port
oh if you want i can ask them separately
um
so so the um the stellaris eight
can have and as well actually the
solaris five
you can combine additional lasers to to
the white dead laser
and one of these additional lasers can
be also the the four
um 405 laser um
and uh what was the the second part
uh can it have five power s detectors
inside and four more on the x1 port
so it can have five internal detectors
yes that's right
and for the for the x1 port
we currently offer two detectives and
those are entities
okay um and we've got time for one more
so
last question is there a light sheet
option
available with this technology
actually yes so we will have also on the
stellaris platform the possibility to
offer
our dls so the digital light sheet
module
and this is available both on the
solaris five as well as on the stellaris
age so on about those
machines
okay well thank you before we go um i'd
like to thank you both
one last time and of course thank the
audience for joining us today
we also want to thank labrutz and our
sponsor leica microsystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
um all the questions that we didn't have
time for today and those that will be
submitted during
the on demand period will be addressed
by the speakers using the contact
information you provided
at the time of registration julia or
petra do you have any
final comments you'd like to make
um actually yes so um i would like to
say and also in the name of julia
thank you very much for taking part in
this webinar i
we hope actually that you enjoyed that
you
had a good time and if you have any
additional questions that you did not
answer
now in this q a just feel free also to
contact your local
leica rep or or contact app
so okay great thank you
and and for that thank you
all right and for the audience this
webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you by email when
it's available for replay
so we encourage you to share that email
with any colleagues who might have
missed
today's event and with that i'll thank
you one last time for joining and hope
you have a great day
you